hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to what may be the true
ending of five nights at Freddy's 2
we're at the 6th night which means the
things are about to get a little weird
and a lot more challenging but hopefully
there's gonna be some story revealed
because they didn't even realize this I
mean I acknowledge it but I didn't
realize it the check for a mr. what's
Fitzgerald here was dated is a prequel
oh my god it really is holy crap how
does it even make sense
bunnies are broken oh my god you were
broken before oh my goodness baby oh my
goodness golly gosh it's so exciting so
exciting it's a goddamn break cool we're
gonna called that ok so I probably need
to start throwing my mask down
yeah that's the stuff
that's a stuff baby that's us stuff it's
gonna do this for a long time max they
say no different
penny no different name no whoa yeah
goodness gravy there's a lot of them
down there but it ain't no different
help help cool yeah okay mangly man
that's okay let's listen to the audio
cues I'll be fine Oh God game is
stressing me out to no end but I'm gonna
finish this strong my fish is so Strang
ain't gonna stop me I know their secrets
I know their secrets now and it blows my
mind that this is a pre quote whoa whoa
it for Spiegelman I wasn't ready for
that
[ __ ] I'm dead oh my god it forced me out
of it it forced me out the camera I
didn't push the button unless I did
accidentally oh my god I'm not ready for
that I have to take a minute to talk
about this the guy on the phone I always
thought he was dead because he died in
the last one but he just said in this
video that he would view it he would put
he would take on the day shift after the
place opened up again and someone took a
suit and went back oh my god the yellow
suit in the back the golden Freddy
someone took it that's what happened to
the kids oh my god but that doesn't
explain why the animatronics to do him
badly in the first place
story's getting a little confusing now
but I'm gonna find the bottom of it I'm
gonna get to the bottom of because this
is now excessively interesting to me I
just got to be careful I may have
accidentally twitched and got myself out
of that
joana gonna have much longer to go
except like a lot we have a lot longer
to go when I said that we didn't have
much to go
I accidentally lied a lot and what I
actually mean to say we have a whole lot
to go on her own I really hope that they
don't throw any oh hi hi Freddie
hi are you there are you hi stop it
cheese don't be I know the balloon kids
they're good
I know oh my god oh let's go damn music
box box are nightmares no you cannot do
that hello are you there
ah it's stressful ye I gotta know when I
have opportunities to charge it up a lot
when I have opportunities not because
that's very important to differentiate
those two moments because if I don't
foxy is going to murder me
flip-flapping crisis whoa pretty lady
how are you doing now that it's been
confirmed that chick is actually a girly
girl
this made life for me so fun I don't
know what hit be fun no read too much
into that you with your traffic guy stop
saying hi it's really annoying okay
okay broken back oh god if that was too
slow I'm gonna no we're fine we're fine
somehow magically we're fine
and we're fine and we're fine Freddie's
just being an observant bugger baby baby
come [ __ ] yourselves
I'll just be here in my Freddy head
please go go
and I this prequel [ __ ] is messing
with my brain I don't know what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna die Oh Freddie
honestly didn't expect you there all
right then it's so unforgiving earlier
version of Sam Bonnie cuz that's what
you is up there with the bad no I know
things are bad things are bad things are
bad they won't give me a chance I'm so
lucky
whoa big guy now ready for you Oh God
Davos at the grabbing of my thing pop
nuggets nuggets god dammit
what did I make it to I don't even know
I wasn't even looking oh my god
[Applause]
okay you foxy foxy was gonna be the big
winner come on down what the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] no no no you can't fool me
I saw him oh my god I saw him what
happens now oh my god what happens oh my
god
oh my god I saw him I flippity doo-dah
saw him I think what I need to do is I
need to spend more time winding up the
music box because I keep doing in
[ __ ] intervals it doesn't get much of
a wind my time is better spent elsewhere
are you there [ __ ] I knew it oh my god I
think Oh what did I do I knew I saw him
why did he go
oh come on it was such a good run
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ] I thought I heard the boy
oh that was a good one too I don't know
why I decided to screw it up I'm just a
big screw-up myself we even bother
sometimes why do I even bother whoa wait
for the wrong button there
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ] the other side I know I
know I did it I know
so dad alright can I go now I was super
fast
could I possibly show the light down
there will you do [ __ ] up the place
goddammit
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] that's what this
is [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
how am I supposed to check everything
all the time all my brain doesn't
process it like it's like it's a rogue
element why the [ __ ] is it Ser piece of
[ __ ] I've been at this about two hours
now I had actually had to walk away from
the computer a little bit to collect my
thoughts this is almost harder than
20-20-20 mode in the original one I had
to load up the game also because my card
was filling up so isn't that lovely
also my camera crashed everything's
going wrong oh well I will get it shall
not be
[Music]
all righty then whoa whoa no golden
Freddy no no what the [ __ ] it wasn't
even in the room it was he was in he was
on the other side which is total
[ __ ] slow now ready for the double
I'm not ready for the triple I got a
headache
one more time one more time yeah I'm
getting it though I'm learning a few
strategies here and there to be able to
help me along my way knowing when to use
the things knowing when to do things
essential absolutely essential come on
[Applause]
nope not today
oh my god you scared the crap out of me
[Applause]
[Music]
oh man that took me about three hours
straight and my god
I am now really good at this game but
either so one more shell oh my god what
is this
where is all that that's not okay
so there's now 10:20 mode
I am very loopy right now I am dizzy I
have a headache but goddamn I'm happy
okay so this was really really hard to
do but hopefully you guys enjoyed it as
far as 10-20 mode judging by how
difficult it was just to do the six
night which was I think I did not expect
it to be that hard it was unbelievably
hard and up to random luck the owners I
won that last one is this because golden
Freddy wasn't the dickbag but I was
starting to get used to him you needed
to throw my ask on and keep it on I was
being very [ __ ] but I got it I got it
so either way if you're waiting for 1020
mode it's gonna be a while I'm not gonna
do this anytime soon I'm flying out to
South Carolina very soon but either way
this
has been amazing is super stressful
takes a lot of skill actually shows that
I'm halfway T's in the game sometimes
but either way it was awesome thank you
all so much for enjoying it thank you
all so much for watching it with me
thank you so much for cheering me on
in my tyre trials of sad whatever I won
that's all that matters thank you all so
much for watching click tonight
annotation for more five nights at
Freddy's stuff that's coming around
maybe I'll get a few more animations out
of this who knows thanks again everybody
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]
another night